comment ils voient castaldi n'était pas
là hier il avait la grippe aujourd'hui
de la plus notre gueule non mais c'est
vrai mais alors ton secret ils le
connaissent déjà très tu vas vendée
devant des brassées sur la plaque non
mais c'est grave mais qui est surtout
une ambiance vacances voient oui c'est
ça hein ce qui est ce qui s kitchen des
boeufs
parce que normalement ça je vous dis à
quoi ça sert sa serre c'est là qu'est ce
qui peut faire à les offrir aux
gonzesses comme ça mais nous on connaît
c'est pour avoir de l'énergie ça m'a
même pas l'énergie tu vas boire alors
que sa dignité ou parce qu'il y avait
été malade il m'a appelé hier matin je
l'aï vu j'ai eu une poussée une poussée
de fièvre due à un virus qui passent et
qui voit le virus qui suivait russie
s'est passé et je suis dit qu'un café
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la juste quelqu'un avec qui j'ai un
problème c'est il ya quelques mois je
connais pas l'émission il ya quelqu'un
qui me qui m'interpelle lâche pas comme
ça tranquillement il ya une personne je
ne connais pas dire je ne sais pas qui
vous êtes qui mollit enchanté moi qui me
dit tu me dises ya quand même un docteur
je connais les missions alors jimmy
mohamed qui est docteur 18 mois m aussi
je te trouve très bronzé alors où tu
t'es foutu de ma gueule aussi parce que
il m'a dit non je peux pas venir tout ça
j'ai dit baye djiby tu sais tu peux
mentir à beinheim mais a besoin c'est
reconnaître une personne bronzer seins
alors ils étaient où celui-ci on était
sur benjamin non oui non alors on va
devenir je me la sévérité un virus qui
passent comme ça alors s'appelle l'arrêt
de travail mito tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
castaldi castaldi je vais poser une
question simple et audois droit dans les
yeux casta way qu'est ce qu'il ya je te
jure que si tu me dis la vérité
ouais je ne m'en voudrez pas mais
j'étais bd est ce que oui ou non tu
avais une vraie grippe hier oui
absolument mais j'ai toujours le soin
tête de mes enfants
[Musique]
t-mac arrêter de mettre samson - il met
à coeur qui bat et métaux remontent la
bocelli avait troublé
oui oui c'est la vérité d'abord est-ce
que je suis un tire-au-flanc non c'est
vrai je sais pas si vous aimez les
flancs non je suis un terreau flanc je
connais pas ce puits sera donc au
travail ensemble 1 c'est vrai ah ouais
mais là hier tu ma famille taux d'
annuler mais tabac mais je le saurai et
castaldi mais bias 39,5
il va durer un jour une grippe qui dure
un jour sa nullité clair ce sont des
merlus a dit russe jamais un virus à
leurs bétails justement retient bien
vous savez quoi
j'ai dit si match qu'il fallait pas
louper et je les ai classer ce soir
pouvoir des mots qui est bas bizarrement
vous êtes 10e l'image la plus pourrie
c'est dommage qu'elle est très drôle
d'animal là c'est quoi alors qu'on fait
quand on veut faire la fête quand on
veut faire la fête et mangue des deux
jolies et parfois ça se passe mal
alors ce lancement c'était quoi 86 mais
vous allez me m'embêter combien de temps
la sueur attaque
si vous êtes saga d'arbitrage tac moi je
n'ai pas le droit de me battre au nord
du tanit a enfin défendu mais qu'il ait
reçu un caleçon un qu'elles sont
sublimes
la marque des célébrités ces dames à des
footballeurs
c'est la marque des gens qu'il aime est
bien vraie question de qualité du
prestige l'avantagent grâce à moi vous
allez goûter bien vous est pas moins 10
vous n'êtes pas moins 20 les -50%
on ne peut pas y résister comme vous
verrez à l'antenne
ma silhouette ne sera plus jamais la
même je vous envoie alors qu'il était
malade
[Applaudissements]
et hop elle donne du jeu ne veut rien
savoir
dieu ne peut rien sans compter ses slips
chansons que j'ai su que je devais
d'abord se méfier slip déjà tu dors tu
as tu des cas d'offre enlève ton slip
ben oui faut mettre conseil puisque tant
par les faits - pierre la mort alors as
tu me cherches tu vas voir on fait nous
passons de produits ça m'arrive
absolument vrai vous avez pris un petit
billet pour ça les normes y avait pas me
parler de fric tous les jours déjà hier
aujourd'hui ça va maintenant
castaldi on va plus avoir sur vous je
vous le dis au bar je vous dirai rien
mais je ne dis plus rien n'allait pas
ces attaques